so thank you for giving me of the
opportunity to come here to Yale and
teach you guys I feel privileged and
hopefully you're a bit privileged to
have you as well but you can decide that
at the end of the week so I'm an
environmentally economist so what I try
to do is a bit of magic well I tried it
to use economic values on nature on
Natural Resources and you might question
why we might want to do that and
hopefully by the end of a week I'll
convert you and make you realise a
valuation is important particularly when
we're going to talk about biodiversity
and the services it delivers to people
so a background to me I've been a
lecturer at Aberystwyth University in
Wales for the last 13 years or so a bris
was a bit for my falsi well color a burr
which is fine but I'm originally
undergrad and PhD was in the Aberdeen so
it gets a bit confusing when you're
talking about Aberdeen in Aberystwyth
but I'm in Wales of them I'm Scottish
so as Pavan said since my PhD I've been
looking at economic valuation of natural
resources my PhD was looking at outdoor
recreation but recently or over the last
ten years have started looking more at
biodiversity in the last five years
we've been looking at the valuation
using an ecosystems approach so very
much a teep approach so I was involved
in chapters 1 & 5 of teeb and I also
looked at the databases for tropical
rainforests mountain and polar regions
I was also called to a certain extent in
UK national like us ecosystem assessment
so it's like the Millennium ecosystem
assessment to the UK but we put money
values on it and I was participating
some of the economic elements of it and
I've done a whole bunch of variation
studies on biodiversity ecosystems both
in the UK and in Africa and stuff in
Malawi Nigeria Uganda Kenya and so forth
so favorite place in Africa last week as
in the Caribbean setting up a survey
looking
ecosystem service values from coral
reefs and some Vincent and we've done
some stuff in the solar mouths
so what I'll try to do over next week is
to pull some of my experience of
undertaking these valuations and try to
link it to the tea process geography ok
so I bracelets here in the west coast of
Wales it's a bit like Yale it's very
much a university time so there's only
12,000 residents and 8,000 students and
it's on the beach and so forth so it's a
lovely place have you ever get a chance
or you fancy doing a PhD even then it's
a great place to study and work ok in
terms of this week today what I'm going
to try and you just give an overview of
why we as environmental economist might
want to value biodiversity and how we T
process can I came about and so forth
so is looking at why we want to value
biodiversity and some of the issues
about doing it and I'll give you some
background or our case study just to
tempt your appetite on valuation then in
the Thursday I'll look at more detail
with valuation tools so we'll look at
the travel cost method contingent
valuation choice experiments and
benefits transfer so we'll go through
step by step out how how you might
undertake those sorts of valuation
studies and giving some examples on that
on Friday we'll look at some of the
methodology collisions so eversince
valuation came about there's always been
some challenges to us and a lot of
debate about whether you can value it is
ethically right there's been questions
about whether the values we develop are
they robust and can be stand-up in
policy appraisals and so forth so
there's a whole bunch of ethical
challenges with the advent of an
ecosystems approach that causes a lot
more challenges as well because we've
got all the uncertainty in the
ecological element as well as
uncertainty in the economic element so
we're still a long way to go to get
perfect but to a certain extent that
makes it exciting
well to research so I'll try and get you
up-to-date with all the kind of latex
gossip going around in the environmental
economic circles about how we value and
approaches to do it okay so today what
we're going to do is just look at the
background of why we value why this
market failure in terms of environmental
economics and so forth
involving market goods so where I'd like
to start from is the team framework that
was used within teeb and I think you
probably came across this or seen it
within T so if we're thinking about
volume biodiversity Necco system
services we need to think from start of
all from a biodiversity so we've got a
natural resource it might be a forest
might be a coral reef and what that
resource does is deliver a whole series
of services I think Tom had a look at
that last day and we look at those
services and where I'm coming in is this
next element is how we look at those
benefits and how we measure the values
of those benefits so that's very much
what we're looking at today looking at
how we look at those different benefits
and it might be economic benefits it
might be social benefits or ecological
benefits largely what a highlight is the
economic benefits but we will discuss
some of the other ones just understand
and then later on in the process in
future weeks we'll look at how or other
people look at how these values feed in
the policy-making process so that's how
what I talk about feed into the whole
process or things so if we're looking at
these different elements of value we
first of all start off with what I call
the economic benefits and as an
environment economists we've came up
with this concept called total economic
value so total economic value comprises
what's called both use values where you
get direct benefits from a natural
resource so a use value might be me
consuming some wild food
that's consumptive use or we might be
getting some non consumptive use of
recreation walking in natural park and
there may be some indirect use values so
things like pollination for the
regulating services and then that's
what's called non use values and
sometimes in the literature it's
referred to as passive use values so
these are things like request value so
the benefit I gained from the knowledge
that biodiversity might be passed on the
future generations are altruistic values
so the benefit I gained czar knowing
that you guys are enjoying the natural
environment so we'll talk more about the
different types of values that we try
and capture his environmental economists
and there's a whole suite of techniques
that we can use to try and uncover and
capture those values so most of what I
talk about this week will be those
economic values and how we can place
economic values within them but there
are also other types of values was
social cultural values so if you go for
a run in the countryside you feel spread
so you lift it so it's much better
running in the forest than it is in the
gym so we get spiritual values those can
really just file do so like ears rock in
Australia the Aborigines get a lot
spiritual value from that and there are
a lot more difficult to try and capture
and as environmental economists we're
only just starting to work out how we
capture those but there's still lots of
questions and how you do that and the
third type is ecological values so
rather than trying through economic
values on Natural Resources there are
ecological indicators that you can use
they might say something about the
health and the clarity of a natural
resource and there might be something
about the critical thresholds at what
point does that system collapse so the
ecologists will have a whole bunch of
ecological indicators of value and if
you're a policymaker you need to think
about the economic values which might be
directly in cost-benefit analysis but
also the social and cultural values
which we might not do economic values on
but still important
for that policymaking process so that's
where we're coming from in terms of the
overall theme framework so in terms of
the structure of the next hour or so the
first thing I'm going to quickly go over
just looking at biodiversity loss and
what we're trying to do to try and stop
it and it's impacts on this then I'm
going to look at how we value mark ere
goods and services so generally with the
way things we value things is through
the market mechanism so I could I do a
sharp and I fall in this worth doesn't
have much of this year $300 or whatever
that's got a market price to it and we
can use that market price to see
something about the value but can we
value forests there's no market for it
supposed to simple production values but
maybe a giant panda there's no market
price for a giant panda so we need to
look at why the markets fail to capture
the price for environmental goods and
then we look at how we can overcome that
market failure I'll see a little bit
more than about total economic value in
the different components of it and how
we might capture and value those
different approaches and then I'll
finish off by doing a quick overview of
different valuation approaches and then
I'll give you example of a choice
experiment where we looked at the value
of cycling and mountain biking in
forests in the UK that give you a nice
example of what valuation can do so
that's the kind of overview for today so
if we look at valuation trends so this
is a paper published last year in
science magazine and it looked at
various indicators of the health of
biodiversity and what we're trying to
look at it and you might not see the
detail but so this is coming from 1970
to 2010 so all these graphs are looking
at indicators of biodiversity over the
last 40 years so here we've got the
while birding there
Living Planet Index and so forth and
what we can see is all these indicators
are showing a decline in biodiversity
this is right way index of endangered
species and again endangered species are
becoming more rare and extinct and the
things like coral reefs mangroves were
quality index so generally what we're
finding from review of indicators on
biodiversity is it globally biodiversity
is declining the variety of plants and
species in the world is declining and
the health of those ecosystems are
declining and what we chart also did
look at the pressures of what's causing
these declines in biodiversity so we've
got things like ecological footprint so
that's how much resources we as
individuals have on the environment and
as you can see over time people are
human society as in the greater impact
them on the world and currently there's
what's called archeological debt they
actually must be about now I'm not sure
which date but it's a day of the year in
which we've used up our annual quarter
of the natural environment so it's
sometime about nine months so for nine
months we've gone past a sustainable use
of a natural resource and it's always
quite funny thinking about ecological
footprints when the first started
talking about in my lectures it was
about November almost getting up to
Christmas and now it's gone before a
starter of my term which starts next
week so it's dramatically shorting or
the resources we're using is greatly
increasing I think like alien species so
as we travel around the world more
foreign species alien species get
transmitted and there's much bigger
problems there and so forth and climate
change
so again generally speaking what's
happening all these pressures that are
happening on biodiversity is increasing
but it's not quite all bad news column
see look at a response so how have we
try to address biodiversity loss and the
things like protective ear and
management sustainable managed forests
policies for alien species biodiversity
aids are given developing countries
money if it protect their biodiversity
and so what we've seen over the last 10
20 years is that we're actually
implementing a lot of new policies to
try and protect biodiversity so so we're
not just saying back in their haunches
thinking ok it's all going to pop but we
are trying to do something to address it
by diversity loss however if you look at
the benefit so these are looking at how
much we gain from the biological
resources so Living Planet Index for
utilize species of various foods and
medicines what we're seeing is even
though we're trying to protect
biodiversity the amount of benefits or
ecosystem services that biodiversity can
deliver us is still declining so we're
not on top of a problem yet and there's
still a lot we can have to do so by
diversity loss is a big issue and
there's growing pressures on it and we
need to try and do something about it so
how is the world try to address it well
through the convention with biodiversity
we aim to try and significantly reduce
the rate of biodiversity loss by 2010
and last year was the International Year
of biodiversity there was a big
international effort to try and promote
biodiversity conservation to reduce
biodiversity loss and the goal from 2000
to 2010 was to significantly reduce rate
biodiversity loss pretty much everywhere
in the world we fail to do that so
biodiversity loss is still happening at
an accelerating rate there are success
stories but the general pattern is
abuddin developed and developing
countries by the Varsity loss is still
being reduced to a significant amount so
one of the key international agreements
to try and protect biodiversity is a
Convention on biodiversity as a whole
series of islands for what to try and
look at new ways of doing it and
recently the by the convention and
biodiversity as adopters ecosystem
approach
there's gonna be trying to push me out
over the next few years but up here are
the targets for the convention and
biodiversity loss as we specified in
2010 what we want to highlight is even
these big international agreements to
protect biodiversity the reason that
they're trying to protect biodiversity
is for our use for for biodiversity
improves benefits to humans not for the
intrinsic values so the policy is not
there just to protect by the first in
its own sake but for issues in terms of
human use
so promoting sustainable use of
biodiversity so it's saying there we
want biodiversity so we can utilize it
for whatever reason but we want to try
and utilize it in a sustainable way to
maintain ecosystem impacted paper
provision includes and services the
support human well-being
so convention and biodiversity
recognizes that biodiversity is
important for us for a whole bunch of
reasons deliver services and therefore
we need to protect that
professional knowledge and so forth very
important development countries and also
the idea of fair and equitable sharing
of benefits of biodiversity loss so a
big section in convention and
biodiversity is looking at how do we
exploit biodiversity but ensure that
people in development countries which
largely are course to the most by the
person biomes in the world that they get
the benefit from it's as a whole bunch
on benefits sharing thing but it is
interesting to know that it's all linked
up to human use so the reasons we're
protecting biodiversity is not the
Advanta value although ecologists would
love to think that but it's for
protecting it for our use so why do we
value by diversity so first reason
biodiversity gives us a whole bunch of
social economic cultural health benefits
and you've probably already seen the
Millennium ecosystem assessment but
that's what really highlighted the link
between biodiversity and the range of
provisioning regularly
culture services and how it delivers
benefits to her benefits that are good
for us what the MA didn't do was trying
to economic value so it's short stop shy
or putting economic values but it did
really highlight globally that
biodiversity deliver services and it's
important to people so so biodiversity
is really important to us but it's on
price so we can't go out to Walmart and
buy a child apart giant panda we can't
go to Walmart and buy a beat be the
pollen ear flowers so there's no market
price we can't go to look at what the
price is and not only does it mean we
don't buy it but there's no measure of
how important it is in terms of economic
times there's no market price but if
something's got no market price does
that mean we ignore it so we want to try
and demonstrate that is important so we
want to demonstrate that people gain
satisfaction so we all enjoy walking in
the woodlands right here or going down
the beach we get a lot of satisfaction
and pleasure from that so it's very
important that we try and capture the
benefits we can otherwise it's ignored
it's ignored and what you do in terms of
your own decision making it might be
ignored in terms of businesses so they
might release pollutions into a river
and cause problems and it might be
ignored in policy making so we want to
try and put a price devalue it to feed
into people and businesses and
government decision making in this year
and I love so a lot of policy I
diversity policies are through
governments and in this era of austerity
in world prices and governments want to
get value for money so the US government
spending millions or billions pounds and
biodiversity conservation it wants to
demonstrate it's getting value for money
and that's another reason why we might
want to value it and so what T was about
was to try and have a global assessment
of the economic banner
from biodiversity across a whole range
of different biomes and rather than a
Costanza world by diversities were 33
trillion which is meaningless she very
much looked at real case scenarios
looking at what biodiversity loss is
going to be or potentially could be over
next few years so T was looking at
marginal value and that's a way issue
Buber by so that's a global assessment
but valuation impede global national
local and so forth so that's kind of
some of the reasons why we might want to
value biodiversity what I want to do is
take a step back and look at how we
value normal goods and services so
conventional goods and services like the
things you buy in Walmart so normally
what happens is an economic market will
be created so you as consumers will have
a demand for a different goods and
services so if I had a big sandwich here
and I said okay how much are you willing
to pay to buy the sandwich if you've
been busy and you haven't had time to
lunch you might say I'll pay ten dollars
where if someone else has been out for a
slap-up meal you're not hungry
thank you're probably not willing to be
$1 so different people will have
different dollar amounts for different
goods and services so fewer people will
have a high price if those guys you're
hungry will have a high price maybe some
people in the diet might have a low
price or something so different people
have different values or how much you're
willing to pay for a product so that's a
demand side that's a consumer then we've
got supply the supply is looking at the
willingness and the ability of firms to
deliver that good so different shops
will have different willingness to sell
sandwiches at different prices so we'll
have different cost curves and so forth
and what the market does is equate this
supplying demand curve and we kept the
market equilibrium and I pick the
Librium we get the market price so that
market price is how much you buy
sandwich from your local grocery sure so
two dollars or whatever sandwiches and
also two pyramids how much
sandwiches are sold over a period of
time and generally speaking that
competitive market system delivers an
optimum level or up in fishin see of
resource allocation so through
interaction our consumers and firms and
through scarce resources we get an
efficient allocation resources so
resources have directed before people
want and there's no wastage and the
market corrects itself says think'll
Adamson have called the invisible hand
so if it's a surplus then what will
happen is the price of the commodity to
decline as you lower price more people
buy it and you clear that surface so
generally speaking this market mechanism
is a very good way of delivering a
scarce resources to maximize benefits
and that's what's the main a question in
economics is about how you allocate
scarce resources so that's great but
I've got here in brackets in the absence
of distortions and this is a problem
with the environment this whole reason
for distortions where we get market
failure so market failure is a big issue
for valuing the environment so markets
often feel developed for environmental
resources we can as I've said before you
can't buy Johnny and panda you can't buy
carbon and so forth so in mainstream
economics the term market failure is the
term used to describe any distortions
that mean that the quality market
equilibrium doesn't reach optimum level
efficiency so there's a whole bunch of
distortions and although the causes of
market failure why during this the main
ones for the environment and natural
resources are public goods externalities
and property rights so I'll go over each
one of these in turn now and describe
why they mean that markets fail so if we
think about different types of goods we
get from one extreme a public good and
then the other extreme a private good so
know everything about our example of a
sandwich a sandwich is a private good
and a private guru there's both rival
and excludable so I've got the sandwich
and I sit here and munch of the week
munch munch munch so its rival and that
if I have the sandwich and eat it then
you can't have it so its rival in
consumption and it's excludable so if I
get by the sandwich I can't think I say
here get your hands off that's mine so a
private good is both rival a excludable
and what that means is is a very
efficient way of dealing with that
there's a whole bunch of rules and
regulations about the private goods if
you buy it then you've got complete
ownership rights of that sorry-ass
includable of its rival so I've got that
sandwich and I can consume it and if I
want to sell that sandwich and I can
pass that public goods are private goods
someone else so all kind of works what
many of environment goods are what's
there on public dudes and a classic
example for public grew this national
defense so if you think about US Army
and Air Force and so forth that gives a
level protection to us and us as
citizens in u.s. it's non-rival and your
consumption so just because you're
getting protected by the army doesn't
reduce a level protection that the other
guys are having so it's non-rival and
consumption everybody is protected to
seem level and it doesn't matter how
many peoples are protected it's also
excludable or non-excludable so you
can't say I don't believe in the army
don't protect me because a whole of us
has protected that nobody can be
excluded from that protective protection
so a public good is non-rival and
non-excludable and if you think about
the environment it's also non-rival
exclude non-excludable so if you go to
the Grand Canyon say for example and
you're looking over the rim then that
view of the Grand Canyon is non-rival so
just because I'm looking out at the
Grand Canyon doesn't stop other people
from also enjoying that experience so
it's non-rival it's not
in consumption until large you stand its
non-excludable so you can't stop people
looking at a landscape albeit there are
parties and so forth but it's no one
rival and non-excludable so make sure
you can read a cartoon but from peanuts
they're saying move away I'm trying to
get a tan I'm not bothering you you're
using up all my Sun but the Sun is non
rival or less you should shadowing it so
the example of rival non-rival so the
idea of public Goosby non-rival
non-excludable it leads to a free rider
problem so what that means is because
you can't stop people from enjoying that
resource people will utilize it without
paying for it
so you might go to Rekha and Canyon and
you have a look at the landscapes and
you'll enjoy it and you can't stop
people from doing that and as a result
because you can't stop people using
light or stopping free riders then it
means as new incentives for private
firms to deliver those resources so if
eyes wanting to so say for example I'm a
farmer and I thought I want to plant
some nice trees and make it look all
pretty and I want to try and charge
people for it in general terms it's very
hard to stop people enjoying that
without paying for it
you could build a ten-foot wall or
something but it's quite impractical so
because you've got a free drug free
rider problem then often private markets
feel to emerge there's new incentives
for individual firms to provide these
resources because they won't manage to
get people to pay for it and as a result
that public good characteristic it means
that the government needs to intervene
and deliver those resources so if you
look at all the environmental policies
biodiversity policies as a whole stream
of them and part of the reason for that
is that private markets went to Vallot
forum so the role of government is to
intervene and provide that resource you
do can't what's called quasi public
public goods and these will be rival but
non-excludable or non rival and
excludable so what that means is
if I went hiking in the Rockies and I
was one thing a wilderness experience
then my walking experience might be
rival if you all UK guys came up in mass
and ruin my wilderness experience so
there may be some rivalry there in terms
of how I perceive my use of resources so
its various examples where it's maybe
not a pure pure public gate but have me
have some elements of rivalry on rivalry
non excludability so often environment
agrees for more in this quasi public
gate but same issues occurred and the
reasons for public intervention deliver
those services
another key key issue for market failure
for the environment is what's called
externalities and an externality is
often the cause of many of the
environmental problems and reasons for
market failure so an externality arises
whenever an individual so it might be a
consumer or a firm or someone and your
production the consumption decisions so
you're going about your normal be lives
or a company factory producing its cues
and services you through your production
and consumption choices which may be
legal and everything but you have a
direct impact on others where those
people haven't chosen to ignore it so
example kind of shown up here is there's
maybe some industry stuff for tying up
upstream and as a result of that I'd
have two firms or individual behavior of
a whole bunch of rubbish in the river
and this is pure fishermen downstream II
wants to catch a fish but because all
the pollution and stuff in the river
then all the fish is dead so that's
example of external or external cost so
what's happening there is a factory is
producing where Ragusa services is
happening and some effluent is going in
the river there may not be illegal for
that effluent it might just be cheapest
way to get rid of it and that's reducing
the fish populations father
stream so when we're talking about the
benefits and cost of environment with
the way the economic markets work is we
often think about private costs and
private benefits so when you are
thinking about whether to buy the next
iPhone when it comes out you I think in
the bio key and iPhones going to cost
five hundred dollars is the benefits to
me that much and you are weighing up
toward your private costs and benefits
or of a fact or farmers producing a
field week he's thinking about the cost
of reductions of fertilizer land
machinery and so forth and the benefits
of the yield so normally what happens in
private markets is individuals or firms
only consider for private costs and
benefits and they base their decisions
on ensuring that the marginal benefits
is greater than the marginal costs but
in environment economics mycological
economics we're more interested in these
social costs and benefits so what's you
over cost to society as a whole so we
need to think about adding and
externalities external costs and
external benefits so external benefit
for example if I'm a farmer and I'm
planting some trees in my farm or say
I'm planting a hedge in my farm I might
only plant enough hedges for controlling
my stock so for stock control but if I
want the extra benefits for in terms
landscape or for enhancing biodiversity
rather than having a 1 meter wide hedge
I might have a 10 meter wide hedge so
external benefits the farmer is only
thinking about or so in terms of private
benefits the farmer is only thinking
about stock control when the appliance
is hedge but as a society we might want
them to also think about the external
benefits to enhancing biodiversity to
enhancing the landscape similarly if a
farmer applies fertilizers on this field
he's thinking about the cost of that
fertilizer in terms of a yield response
what he's not thinking about its any
potential costs of pollution associated
with that fertilizer in fact fertilizer
gets leach in the river upsets fish
populations and so forth so
as an environmental economist we are
very keen to try and capture these
external costs and benefits and try and
feed them into decision-makers and
ultimately what we'd like to happen is
that policies then internalize these
external costs and benefits so that
decisions are based on public benefits
or source of benefits so to go through
an example of the cost of a production
externality so if we imagine a farmer
having a field of wheat and the decision
he makes relates these marginal benefits
and marginal private costs so do you all
understand what we mean by marginal
change in economic terms so marginal
changes the food costs our benefit from
increasing IP by one extra unit so if a
farmers want to try increases marginal
benefit so he applies fertilizer and she
apply more important for yield response
declines so after a certain number of
fertilizer applications the response at
yield has declined so generally your
private marginal benefit declines and
similarly your marginal private costs
increase so as you try and increase
yield production your yield of wheat you
might have to go into more marginal land
and it's going to cost more to do it and
so forth so you can't generally then
margin fie the costs increase and so if
the farmer is thinking about producing
this level of production then you've got
the marginal benefits is much greater in
this marginal cost
so therefore what happens is he says
well if I increase iboot then I will get
extra benefit of that amount so he keeps
increasing IP till aesthetical Librium
point if he goes beyond that there in
his private costs of benefit on his
private benefit so if he produces too
much it's from the costs of money so if
he can work out these marginal private
costs and benefits here come to a sec
illiberal and say okay I'll produce at
that level production so each decision
maker will make that sort of decision so
it's based on his own private costs and
benefits but now
that by applying these fertilizers
there's external cost so those the
paralyzers get leached out in the stream
it means that water quality is reduced
that reduces fish populations and so
forth so it's an external cost to
society of what we use environmentally
economist argue is that we should be
looking at marginal social costs which
is a summation of the marginal private
costs of this line and the marginal
external costs
so those externality is a distance
between those two lines so what we as
environmental economist is trying to do
is say okay can we measure this external
cost or if it's a benefit it might be a
new line here so can we measure it value
about external cost and can we
internalize it straight through some
environmental taxation or something and
what we don't say it's okay the optimal
level of output is not this market
equilibrium here but an environment like
the Librium where the marginal social
benefits equal and marginal social cost
so what we're saying is we internalize
those externalities what's most
efficient for society as a whole it's a
lower level of reduction and if we take
a difference between the change in the
marginal external cost the marginal
external benefits from the original
level to new level then this difference
here is a social cost of a free market
so in terms of economic theory by
allowing firms to only think about the
marginal private costs and benefits
we're missing out in this whole bunch of
benefits or so that's a cost of
pollution to society and so what polls
he tries to do is internalize certain
case cases to be the marginal external
cost we try and internalize that
marginal external costs so firms take
account of it so we might charge farmers
attacks for using fertilizers that
increases the cost of the private cost
of I merge of benefits to farmers so the
internalized external costs and they
reduce production so ideally we could
work
allow this be one way of setting up the
price for different policies so
externality is a really important reason
why is market failure and therefore we
need to post intervention in markets the
third reason was property rights so if I
buy an acre of land I there's a whole
system about frying properties if I buy
an acre of land
I've got whole ownership rights of that
acre of land so I can grow up wheat on
it I can get a couple of cows on it and
I can sell those cows or I can write it
out to some other person they give me
rent and they can do something else if I
find oil underneath it then I can
extract it so with private property
rights once you've got ownership rights
and there's a legal system backing you
up you've got full use of that resource
I'm assuming you want to have benefit
streams from that resource into the
future then what happens is you'll
manage that resource sustainably so you
won't really try and get the most of out
of the land you won't try and destroy it
you're trying is your that land is
sustained in a way that you'll get
benefits for long term future so private
property rights is a good thing where it
falls down is if you've got what's
called open access property rights so
we're private property rights aren't
clearly specified and in 1968
Geron hard and famous paper called the
tragedy of economy the Colemans
and what he tried to do is demonstrate
the fact if property rights aren't
clearly specified then that causes
degradation of a resource so you've got
plot of land here the Commons to be used
by whoever wants we're saying as a piece
of land and anybody can use it so if
you've got three farmers here and they
are saying whoa I can maybe chuck double
the number of cows on that piece of land
because the more it's not going to cost
me anything I can really push a
livestock on it
and I'll get lots of benefits so all
these farmers are saying yes real and
let's utilize it and they're also saying
I'm not going to apply fertilizer to it
because if I spend money applying
fertilizer and these other two farmers
will also benefit from it so it's not
worth me investing in so what then
happens in this plot of land you get a
little bit grazing so you get a
utilisation of that resource and little
investment and as a result you get
destruction of the Commons so at the end
of the day you completely destroy that
resource so this concept that there's no
specified property rights is really
what's really important and in terms of
thinking about how we manage global
resources and particularly if you think
about the atmosphere nobody owns the
atmosphere and all sea oceans nobody
owns ocean so people don't things in it
and as a result we might get destruction
so Hardin's ideas were great apart from
one thing
you used a bad example so white uses ID
of a common than in the UK we get common
property rights where it's made before
top of the hill and where a number of
farmers might be able to great sheep on
that land but with common property
resources before it is as a number of
people have rights to utilize that land
but as part of that rights they were
only allowed to raise a certain number
of sheep on that land and there's rules
and regulations about how you pay for
investing in land so a common property
resource can be well managed so though
equals the tragedy of the Commons
Colman's are a type of property rights
whereas multiple owners and you get
similar things in developing countries
where as common resource use for the
rain forest or a bit land and so forth
so what he's actually describing is
what's called an open access resource so
if you've got an open access resource
like the global Commons then what
happens is if you think about fishing in
the ocean and what happened in your fine
land is everybody kept fishing and
fishing and fishing more and more and
eventually they can have fished out of
the hole
and Island Newfoundland and the fish
officially crashed so that was example
of people not investing or not making
good use of that resource everybody
thank it most out of it and eventually
that resource crashes so open access
resources is a source of market failure
not common property resources okay so we
we've shown how the market works through
supply and demand of get market price
for things and for the environment and
biodiversity
there's externalities of public goods
and open access resources these are
reasons why markets feel to emerge for
it so it's new market price so we can't
say that landscape is worth $50 or
whatever so how can we actually value
that resource how much is a red squirrel
worth any ideas someone has actually
worked it out but I can't remember what
it is
so we'll look out for my methods and how
we might value in a moment but when
we're talking about how we value things
and we will talk about what's called
total economic value it's important to
recognize that the way we
environmentally columnist value things
is different to a market price so a
Bradlee shown in this market model and
the market price is for interactions to
find a man baguette this market price so
a sandwich is worth five dollars or
whatever and we can work out the total
value of sandwiches an economy by
multiplying the price of that sandwiches
by the number of people eating those
sandwiches
I don't know us sandwiches might be
worth a million dollars a week or
something but after you remember from
the start with a sandwich example those
of you guys haven't had lunch although
the market price might be $10 if I had a
sandwich here said how much you're
willing to pay for it
some people might be willing to pay $10
for it
and some people might not like prawn
sandwiches so they might only be willing
to pay 50 cents for a sandwich or be not
hungry so different people have
different willingness to pay and
abilities to pay for different resources
and what we get here so the guy who's
hungry willing to pay $10 for sandwich
for the market price is only $5 we get
what's called the consumer surplus this
is a kind of really bonus points this is
how much extra benefit you gain from
consuming that sandwich over and above
the market price so when you buy
different things in the shops your
decision is am I willing to pay this
market price for it and if you say yes
you purchase it so you'd be somewhere on
here if you say no that's too expensive
if I won't get the benefits you'll be
somewhere down here it's not worth the
price to you but for some of you you'll
get you'll be willing to pay a lot more
than the market price for that and that
extra value on top of the market price
is called the consumer surplus if we
think about environmental resources now
there's no markets there's no market
price then in theory market price is
zero so the price here is zero and
therefore because there's no market
price consumer surplus is all that
people are willing to pay above the zero
market price so when we're trying to
environm
and file the environmental resources
what we're trying to do is value how
much people are willing to pay for that
market price so we're looking at
measures of consumer surplus not
consumer surface is it Arion the demand
curve so much what we try and do in
terms of valuation is try and find a
normal way to work out what the market
price is for that resort sorry what
people's willingness to pay is for that
resource and therefore we work out the
consumer surplus so when you look at
studies at Value environmental resources
what we're doing is measuring most cases
that consumer surplus and that consumer
surplus is very different from the
market price so it's very different
theoretical backgrounds to it so you
can't really directly relate economic
values to market prices from not
measuring the same thing I think a lot
of people forget about that so that's
what we're trying to do is
environmentally economist work out the
consumer surplus so when we're thinking
about values then we as environmental
economists that came up with this
concept called total economic value so
what we're saying is market price is
very narrow almost whole bunch of other
ways people benefit from environmental
resources so we start with total
economic values and we can split them
between what's called news values and
non use values often these non news far
these are just described in terms of
passive use values so the two terms are
seen on use and passive use just an
extent depends which side the Atlantic
Ocean you sit on so if we could only
work away across it so use file use and
we get I shall use so you as a consumer
you're actually using like resource
you're going out in the countryside and
so forth and we get consumptive use so
if we've got a patch of land then we
might have use might have crops on it we
might have livestock there might be wild
foods would get picked berries from
trees and so forth or fish meat so
there's a whole bunch of uses that you
consume it and what's important there is
once you kind of picked your berries
from the tree then you're consuming it
so that berries gone for that season
so that's consumptive use often there's
market prices for reefs consumptive uses
so things like crops and livestock sand
fish race there will be a market price
so there's no real problem measuring in
value of those then the consumptive use
value so these things have like if I go
walking in Grand Canyon
so the recreation tourism values like in
a lot of kind of spiritual enlightenment
see this massive hole in the ground it
looks great
but I'm not actually consuming that so
maybe consuming it with my eyes but I'm
not I'm not taking away so it's
non-consumptive use but we get a lot
well-being from that another
under-researched
area of consumptive uses education and
research so if you think about sea
Antarctica and Iceland and so forth
where we've got all these curves of ice
so you can bear it into the ice
we've got information about for last ten
twenty thirty thousand years about
climate and so forth so research and
education can get a lot of benefits to
us indirectly so there are non
consumptive use then we've got indirect
use and often these interact uses are
the regulating services so the
pollination the climate change sex quest
raishin and so forth flood protection so
you don't directly benefit from bees
flying around because they're just
getting on with their job but you
benefit if they pollinate apple trees
and so forth so we get indirect benefits
from these regulating services and we
need to think about novel ways of
looking at that so we're still using
those resource but the benefit we get is
indirect Dennis what's called option
value so here what we're saying is we're
not actually utilizing that resource but
I want that resource to be there in the
future but potentially I can use it so
for example say a giant panda I might
have no immediate plan to go to China to
look at giant pandas in the wild but I
want to know the knowledge at some point
in the future if I decide to go there I
can see them so it's an option value of
utilizing that resource in some way or
similar it might be protecting the Grand
Canyon and so forth so option value is
it can a bit more of a line but it's to
value or the satisfaction you know that
that resource for your possible use in
the future even though you might not
plan to use it now don't we start
getting a bit eerie theory with these
non you
values service requests and altruism
values so request values is it's a
benefit you gain from knowing that a
resource will be retained for future
generations or from your kids or from
other people kids so it's not the pet
value you came for your own use but the
value for future generations and
altruistic is for other people within
your own generation so these types of
values are based on the benefits you
gain or some satisfaction in knowledge
that resource is sustained for other
people to use either in this generation
on future generations and then there's
what's called existing values and that
is where you came benefits from knowing
that by diversity or whatever exists for
the sake of an ecosystem so without
really linking to human use per se but
still your satisfaction knowing by
diversity who exists for its own right
there's also another type of value I
titled economic value called intrinsic
value and then trinsic value is a value
that by diversity exists for its own
right without any link to human
wellbeing so and those gonna bit of a
debate between existence and the
forensic values and kind of separate
them but existence values generally
linked to the benefit humans gain from
knowing that biodiversity exists where
intrinsic is just by diversity
existences own right and doesn't have
any anthropocentric importance okay so
there's a whole range of different types
of value so we've got direct indirect
option and non use from a previous
diagram and what's useful to do is link
it to different types of ecosystem
services which I think you covered
previously so provisioning regulating
cultural so provisioning services we get
the right age so things like crops and
so forth we can utilize crops and things
like the option value so we might get
benefits from the
using that resource in the future
regulating is very much indirect values
so the benefits from pollination so we
indirectly get benefits on pollination
that they mean as figure better apple
harvest and so forth
a similar live option is meaning that
this potential use in the future then
cultural services things like recreation
tourism culture we kept direct year so
we actually go to recreation sites and
enjoy it and we get option use for
enjoying it and also there's this non
use for a cultural value so we want that
experience be passed on to future
generations and so forth and then this
is last one because supporting services
or Antibes we called it habitat and
supporting services so these things by
nutrient cycling soil formation and
generally what we think there is soil
formation doesn't actually give us
benefit so just the fact there's more
soil we don't benefit from that but by
farming soil it'll feed in these other
types of services so when we try and
value environmental resources
provisioning regulating cultural
services have what are called final
products or final services we already
support entire intermediate services so
we do indirectly benefit from them so
that's kind of showing how four
different types of total economic value
linked to echo different or different
ecosystem services one thing you didn't
pick up contributions charities how many
people contributed WWF for other
environmental charities the ratio really
mean
so what you're doing there is your
freely giving up $10 $100 whatever for
not for an organization which will
hopefully better manage in natural
environment you don't have to do it but
something within you says yes I believe
in the natural environment and I think
it should be protected what we can do
similar ways in the contingent valuation
method we can ask people what your
maximum will needs to pay for an
environmentally source contribution
should charge he isn't a good way of
doing contingent valuation because
people tend to have a certain level
payment to give to charity so it kind of
biases results but this Lao idea has
been used to develop so there are kind
of direct payments waiting you to
directly contribute or pay for the
environment some indirect payments a
higher hi sprite is an inflated area so
it's a famous paper from a guy called
O'Brien on Atlanta Airport and he looked
at the difference in house prices from
distance from airport and can't remember
exact value but something like for each
decibel reduction in house prices the
house or sorry each decibel reduction in
noise increase house prices by about $50
or something I can't remember exact
amount but there was a very strong
relationship within airport noise and
house prices so that and that
methodology is called hedonic pricing so
is looking at difference in the house
prices related to the environment or
good or bad we discussed this people are
willing to pay extra for clean spring
water even though you can get for
nothing so what is we as environmental
economist have done have kind of thought
about these concepts and then thought
well hi can we use this sort of
information to prove a value on
environmental resources and we came up
with a whole bunch of different
techniques and on Thursday I'll just try
these techniques in more detail but well
do just now is just give you a little
flavor for them and I'll finish off with
a more tea
for example going through a choice
experiment so there's a whole bunch
what's called direct market valuation
approaches and what these days use
actual market data so currently market
successful well from environment agreed
so there might be some market prices so
for example bottled water we know that
there's a market for a portal water we
can see something about that for clean
water more recently there's been carbon
markets so to shy the price for carbon
so we can look at the cost of carbon
sequestration in terms of the carbon
price as a market developed for that and
to certain centers B moves to try and
generate markets for environmental goods
it's not the sole purpose for trying to
valuation but there is a whole bunch of
markets for environmental goods and and
some of them we can use to infer an
information so market price face
approach is just general supply and
demand and we can draw in some market
prices cost base approaches the example
of water filtration so if we want to
make sure that New York has clean
drinking water we can either invest in
protecting or enhancing a wetland that
will naturally clean up the water or we
can do some engineering solution so come
and we can look at the cost of that
engineering solution so engineering
solution might cost five billion dollars
to create or maybe five million dollars
whatever but we can say something about
the benefits of natural wetland
filtration system by comparing it to the
costs of creating an engineered solution
and if you've got an engineered solution
the cost base approach it doesn't say
anything about how much people are
willing to pay for that resource so it's
kind of a replacement cost this is how
we can place a that filtration system
but it's nothing to do with the actual
benefits so it so a crossface approach
yes it does gives an indication of the
value or the cost of replacing those
functions or services but it doesn't
actually say anything about the value so
there's differences between the cost of
something and the value and so when
we're talking about total economic value
a lot of these and similar I said about
market price
it's only a device in market price not
consumer surplus so okay so there are
these cost based approaches they don't
measure total economic value while they
do give aprox a - and some indication of
how important it is so they are used and
they are quite important then the next
to the field preferences stated
preference they tend to try and reflect
more elements of it all week no week
value so what happens here is the value
of a natural resource is revealed
through people's choices so a travel
cost method produces a Grand Canyon
example when all you guys who've been
the chronic Canyon you've revealed your
preferences for visiting the Grand
Canyon in terms of how much you're
willing to pay but as we'll show on
Thursday just because you paid $100 for
a flight to Arizona that doesn't reflect
the full benefit you gain from Grand
Canyon so someone you might be willing
to pay five hundred pounds to go there
some might be a thousand pounds so the
actual cost that you incur
does really nice relate to the value but
what we can do is get some of that cost
information and convert it into a demand
curve and that gives us a value so I'll
describe that more detail next day but
the travel costs who are doing is we're
trying to get some information about the
value you have for a resource by your
actual real actions by you going through
Grand Canyon and from that information
we can work out demand curve and value
similarly hedonic pricing so difference
in highest prices of whether it's
airport noise or
a beach view or not we can get some of
that information an issue with photonic
pricing is it's very difficult to find
two identical houses that where the only
difference is that environmental
resource so they might have different
number of rooms they might be next to
new good school or whatever so what you
have to do is get a whole bunch of
houses and do a regression where one of
those attributes is that environmental
good how much airport noises are so
forth the nice thing about these
revealed preference techniques is
they're based on real behavior so people
are actually going to crank Canyon
people actually find the houses so it's
a great great thing about the field
preference or based on actual behavior
rather than the stated ones which are
hypothetical behavior we'll talk about
in a moment so it's a very positive
thing for revealed preference one of the
limitations is the only to use value so
we're only looking the value for people
actually going to Grand Canyon they're
not saying anything about those of you
who haven't been there and you'd love to
but you haven't been there yet or people
who want to pass it on to future
generations so they'd see nothing about
non use values um this is largely where
stated preference values methods come in
so state preference methods can value
both use and value non use values and
what they basically are is a
questionnaire where you describe an
environmental good and you ask people
how much you're willing to pay to get
that environmental good so you create
this hypothetical market so the reason
for that create a hypothermic kid is we
already said this market failure for
environmental goods but somehow we need
to persuade people that we could
possibly introduce that market so it
might be we say that government's going
to introduce a policy to enhance
biodiversity how much you would be
willing to pay for that so early
contingent valuations had an open-ended
question where he said are you willing
to pay X dollars for this or or no sorry
yes what what's the maximun you willing
to pay and you don't normally do
when you don't go in the Walmart and say
the Takashi Oh says how much you willing
to pay for that sandwich you're offered
to price and you say I'm willing to be
at that price or not
so in contingent valuation now the way
we say it is that this policy will be
offered will the cost you say ten
dollars a year and increased taxes are
you willing to pay that ten tall order
to get those benefits so that's called
the discrete choice
so we'll stock for about continued
valuation but you're using
questionnaires and asked people are you
willing to pay a certain amount for that
product and different respondents will
have different amounts and you look at
the portion of people saying yes to
different amounts choice modeling it's
kind of similar but rather than asking
them to say I do want to be a certain
amount you give different policy options
and I'll give an example in the moment
for all of that so again using
questionnaires the finest value transfer
so if you couldn't undertake some of
these surveys it cost a reasonable
amount of money
so generally evaluation study I've been
doing over the last few years I've been
about say three hundred three hundred
thousand dollars or so is how much it
costs to do one of these surveys so if
you're a government you want to find for
the valley different environment things
that's going to cost a lot of money and
for cheaper pavan was trying to value it
was fifteen biomes and twenty two
services across those biomes wherever I
comes out with about four hundred
different values then that's going to be
really difficult to do so what you do is
file a transfer so what you can do if
you're a policymaker rather and
commissioning you studies all the time
you can look at existing studies so
maybe I've done a studying forest
recreation in UK and then if you're
interested in forest recreation in your
forest you can maybe transfer the values
I came up with adjusted them to suit
Yale and put that value so just to
finish off I won't give an example of I
study a recently dead for death row
which is UK Department Environment Food
and Rural Affairs and it was looking out
the ecosystem benefits from by the UK by
diversity action plan so new UK
biodiversity action plan
we've identified by 20 different habitat
types in UK there's about 200 different
species where their specific actions to
conserve these different species and the
government was interested to find out
how much people willing to pay for those
species and within the valuation
framework what you have to do is look at
different scenarios so rather than to
Costanza fathering nature in UK what
we're trying to do is look at the value
of that policy instrument and we had two
scenarios of the value of the current
biodiversity action plan so what the
current benefits were retaining from the
current policy compared to a
counterfactual where if a government
stopped funding by diversity policy and
biodiversity declined so it was looking
at was it benefit from what's happening
and secondly what would be extra
benefits of biodiversity action plan was
fully implemented to achieve all the
targets so currently we're not quite
meeting all the targets and they could
spend more money to achieve those
benefits we looked at 17 different
habitat types in the UK so we tried to
value 17 different habitats and also we
broke UK into twelve regions so Scotland
Wales Northern Ireland to nine year each
ins of England we tried to look at the
value across those different regions and
to do that idea with that was to test
some benefits transfer and I'll talk
about those results on Friday so in
terms of a choice experiment what we do
is we identify or we we identify four
different types of benefits you might
attain from despite diversity policy of
what we try to do is set help in the
camera millennium ecosystem assessment
framework so we've got provisioning
regulating and cultural service or
provisioning is wild food so food such
as berries and mushrooms you can pick
from a natural environment we use market
prices to look at commercial values of
crops but we're looking at what food can
be harvested
nicely and non-food products was things
you might collect so corns and and
things medium and dry food and natural
products we realized that non-food was
maybe that important but we try to have
a couple of provisioning services in
terms of regulating us climate
regulations or trees through sort carbon
people and habitat store carbon and so
forth so we're looking at carbon
sequestration water regulation so having
forests will reduce flood risks so if it
rains forests will slow down the passage
of water that means it's more even flow
of water and have more regular flows and
rivers central places kind of landscape
so what the landscape looks like within
that habitat thing those kind of
benefits and then we looked at
threatening charismatic species so birds
mammals and per diems reptiles morphs
and butterflies for things you could
probably recognize and there are
specific action plans for a number of
these species and there's less
charismatic species of plants insects so
maybe things you don't recognize but
they're still protected under this
policy so what we did is trying identify
a series of seven ecosystem services
that might be delivered through the
policies to protect and enhance these
different habitats in the UK and what we
then did in the choice experiment is we
looked at different levels or the
provisions so we've said what's
currently delivered what might be
delivered if we enhance or increase the
policy provisions to enhance those
services of what might be happening if
we we walk away from it so what might be
a decline and so what the respondent
gets is a choice of these three policy
options and for reasons I'll explain
next day is we always have a baseline so
this baseline scenario is that
government walks away from biodiversity
action plan policies we can't decline in
all these ecosystem services so
basically what's happening is look at
less carbon store
we'll get more flooding species will
starting declining and so forth so
that's kind of the worst case scenario
and then we have these different options
where all these different services are
one of three levels there might be
decline in the current level or enhanced
level so it's different combinations of
these in option a and option B and
they'll cost you different amounts
so for option A so you'll get say for
example less flooding more species and
so forth will cost you 75 pounds an
option P we get more habitats maintain
more species so we get different
combinations and that'll cost you three
five pounds yeah per high school per
year it's an increase in tact so we're
saying the government will funders for
an increase in tax so this is how much
your tax bill will increase to get those
benefits so we use an experimental
design to decide how much or what levels
or these services are in these two
scenarios I'll describe that design
later but you can think about the
moments can the random and so if what
you respondent need to think about is
well do I to care about these benefits
are the important to me - am I happy to
get some benefits over this decline
scenario so other benefits were filed
and then if I want those benefits am I
willing to pay these amounts so for
example I might think I like these
benefits here but there's no way I'm
going to pay 75-pound to get them so I
might say well I don't like that one I'm
not going to choose it's too expensive
what about this one 25 pounds am I
willing P 25 pounds for ease benefits
and if I say yes and I'll choose that
one
but if 25 pounds are still too much I'll
choose this this baseline scenario where
it doesn't cost me anything so what
you're doing is responding it's making
trade-offs between the different levels
of benefits with a cost and through
experimental design you'll get a whole
series of the different choice tasks so
I think in this study there are probably
about 16 different combinations of the
choices and through those different
combinations we can get a value for
different levels of each of those
different benefits circuses and benefits
so I'll describe this more next day but
like it was a flavor of the critical
choice tasks and each responder might
get between five and ten of these choice
tasks so and they're all different terms
of the levels of services and option A
and B and the different costs amount and
through frontier regression we can work
out a marginal value for each one so
that was the first element to choice
experiment what we're doing the choice
experiment is looking at how much people
value the different services further
aspect of this research was we were
trying to look at the benefits from
different types of habitats so you might
not see people here but you'll get a
general yes they're just so here's
example of six different habitats which
we looked at and these are different
services so it's kind of probationary
it's a production of food its climate
change water regulation war purification
pollination Center plays charismatic
species non charismatic species so the
y-axis is or so what we basically did
was we asked a whole bunch of ecologists
on ecosystem experts to say how does
this habitat deliver different levels of
services and their relative scale to one
so we had a kind of point system so it
really kept blanket bogs so it's a kind
of peatland habitat planket bogs are
actively growing so they store a lot of
carbon directly water flows they're
quite important for Karris Mattox or
species where if you look at arable
fields they've got lots of commercial
foods been growing the arable fields but
an arable land doesn't really provide
much different services so what we've
got here is an expert assessment of a
relative levels of delivery of different
services by different habitat types so
that's saying okay how does a habitat
heads-up
I can bulk deliver service but what we
are important or interested in this
study was how much does a biodiversity
conservation policy contribute to
hunting a service delivery so what we
also are the experts which is the right
bit here is what's the additional
contribution of the conservation policy
to enhance in the service delivery so
this level here blue bar is how much
services currently delivered and the red
bar is how much extra service will be
delivered through the implementation of
that policy so we've kind of got these
broad results for this and there's a
whole bunch of caveats with this and the
ecologists were a bit nervous of it but
in general terms I think the Tryon seem
reasonably reasonable so what we then
did now was we to the choice experiment
data combined it with this data and
tried to work with overall benefits so
the current policy it's worth to be 3.1
billion pounds a year and we extended
the policy it would be 75 billion pounds
a year science overall benefits and if
you look at the costs it's a benefit
cost ratio about four to one but it will
be different habitats
so before we first demonstrated there's
a benefit called ratio about four to one
overall what's probably more interesting
is oh sorry and we looked at how
different services so currently the most
important service is climate regulation
and water regulation so these are the
types of services that the policy
deliver that are most important to
people in UK I simply we look at the
fulham of the patient the extra benefits
again we see that those are important as
well as charismatic species where are
things like while through the non-food
products people don't really care about
it which is kind of to be expected to a
large extent so you can see what
services different people value and
finally
we can look at how different habitats
have different values so things like
blanket bulbs which sewer carbon and
regulate water on the per hectare basis
they deliver highs blue lines are the
current services and right there's the
enhanced services so blanket bogs purple
myrtle and grass we should like Heather
of course the floodplains and native
woodlands are the habitat types that
deliver more services per hectare and we
can get information and I could split
this up almost into different ecosystem
services but I think if you disaggregate
the data that much you start inducing
lots of errors so I think what we've
demonstrated in this research is
different habitats are important deliver
different services and through the
conservation policies is where actually
get involved you for money for delivery
those services so I think the time is up
so just to summarize today generally
speaking economic markets have failed to
deliver environmental goods there's no
market price for them and so but people
still gain benefits from it and what
we's environmental economists have had
to think about novel ways in which we
can catch up those values either through
revealed preference techniques travel
cost or stated preference choice
experiments